So using the information from my mitochondrial chromosome
the SNVs we can trace my maternal line.
>> Exactly. you got your mitochondrial DNA from your
mother, she got it from her mother. And she
got it from her mother and so on and
so let's take a look at your mitochondrial DNA.
>> Okay. Alight, and what I'd like to do now, is focus on
the maternal line. So let's go back up to the menu, My Results.
>> 'Kay.
>> And under Ancestry Overview,
we see Maternal Line, which is what we've been talking about. and then.
>> Oh, wow. So I have my maternal line from J2A1A
And what does that mean exactly? So if you remember when
we looked at the rest of your chromosomes they indicated a
lot of ancestry from Britain and Ireland. And J2 is a
[INAUDIBLE].
It's also very common in Europe and different parts
in Europe. and it's a lineage that arrived in
Europe maybe 45,000 years ago. So that's something that
you inherited from your mother. So, if you were
to trace back you, you know, and get to
know who you're relatives were through your maternal line.
You'd find that they all, that they, you probably
were living in Europe, different parts of Europe. And maybe
if you went far enough back, if you
went 45,000 years you'd probably find that they
were on the Arabian peninsula, in the Near
East. and if you went even further back, you'd
find that they were in Africa. Because if we, all of us, when we trace our
ancestry, a single lineage of our ancestry far
enough back, we'll find that it traces to Africa.
>> Now interestingly, I actually have my, my own father is in the 23andMe.
>> Aha. Okay.
>> Group 2, and I notice that he and I have the same mitochondrial subgroup.
>> Right.
>> Now, does that mean we're related?
>> That means that you have a common maternal ancestor.
And it could be back, you know, thousands of years.
>> I see.
>> yeah. But that's kind of cool, you know?
>> Mm-hm.
>> To share that maternal ancestry. It's not,
you did not inherit it from him. But
both of you have a maternal ancestor, if
you go back far enough, the same maternal ancestor.
>> And now,
what about Roy King, who we looked about earlier?
>> Okay.
>>
>> Let's find, so.
>> Roy is.
>> Roy has a lineage called L2C, and that lineage is
very common in Western Africa. And if we recall Roy's overall ancestry
chromosomes 1 to 22. about half of it traced back to Africa.
But what we see by looking at his maternal line is that,
specifically, If he goes back the mothers, you know?
his mother's mother's mother's mother's mother came from Africa. and
what I'd like to do is compare that with
his paternal line, I mean when I get a chance.
>> Okay.